It is the seventh week of term. And
in this class, if you've kept up,
you have red nine novels in seven weeks.
So if you kept up, I want you right
now to pat yourself on the back.
Oh, I don't see a lot of padding. Okay.
If you just missed one novel,
yeah.
Okay. I don't want to look
do your padding later. Um,
let me say that you have
broken the back of the course.
Not to use too violent metaphor.
It's the seventh week.
We have six weeks left.
In those six weeks we have five
count them, five novels. That's it.
And one of them you get to choose.
So instead of doing two novels in a week,
you'll have a week and a
half for one novel. Uh,
this is a much more humane pace.
Why are you laughing? It's not funny. Um,
you also of course have spring break.
If you use spring break wisely reading
somewhat leisurely way and myrtle beach
as you're relaxing on the beach blood
meridian, excellent beach novel,
you'll be in great shape. You'll be
riding high through the rest of the term.
Easy peasy.
Okay.
Why did I do that to you these last
three weeks? Why did I do that?
Well, one reason, as I said
at the beginning of class, uh,
at the beginning of the term is that
I did not want you to be crushed after
spring break. I want you
to be crushed now. Um,
so it'll be better later.
But there's another reason.
So why did my disc draw
point of those novels? Well,
my lecture today is in part
an answer to that question.
A syllabus is not a parade.
It's not a succession of
novels that passes by and we
wave and we catch whatever
candy or beads they throw at us.
And then we go home at the end of the day
with sore feet from standing too long.
It's not like that.
A syllabus,
at least in this kind of class.
And with me teaching it is an argument.
It's an argument about a
whole historical period.
It's an argument about a chunk
of literary historical history.
It's an argument about the evolution
of an art form in a particular place in
time.
In order to preserve that
quality of a syllabus,
you have to read quite a bit.
Reading quite a bit means that you can
begin to see the lineaments of larger
trends and movements in
that historical period.
It allows you to amass enough evidence
to build an intellectual understanding of
what's going on in this period.
If I had dropped a novel,
there are certain kinds of arguments I
would not have been able to make and the
argument that I'm going to make for you
today would not be as compelling as I
hope it will be.
Okay,
so as in the Franny and Zooey lecture,
I tried to demonstrate for you in a
very self conscious way how literary
scholars make local arguments that
take into account an entire novel,
its major features and use
the evidence of detail,
the level of text to support
those kinds of claims.
Today I'm going to make a much broader
argument of the kind that literary
scholars are often interested in making.
I'm going to make an argument
about a major trend in this period.
Okay.
And to do that,
I will use evidence and I'm going to
call on you to help me put together the
evidence for broader claims that cross
novels and argument of this kind has a
different quality from those more local
arguments about individual novels that
I've made each week.
Okay.
It's different in the sense that I want
and most literary scholars want such
arguments not to be totally
counterintuitive in the
way that you can sometimes
take pleasure in making a
reading of a local novel,
counterintuitive for the big arguments
you want to be able to account for what
is obvious about the period,
but perhaps has not been justified
as an analysis of the period.
So you want a sense of inevitability
that this argument you're making explains
all kinds of things that people have
always noticed about that period.
In the same way that when I
lectured on Franny and Zooey,
I asked you what was obvious to you
about the novel and then my argument went
around and spoke back to those
things at different points.
So this general argument aims
to speak to those obvious parts,
but it speaks more strongly
to those obvious perceptions.
And so, uh, I, I'm launching into
a different kind of argument.
What I want to talk to you about today
is a particular narrative form and
convention.
And I'm calling it the identity plot.
Certainly I am not the first scholar
to think about identity as a form of
narrative in this period.
And it's precisely because I am not the
first that I can give it this sort of
name.
There's so much work that's been done
excavating how identity works in the novel
in this period that it has become
something we know a lot about.
What hasn't been said before is
that it has this particular name,
and I use this name because
for me the identity plot,
which I will explain in a few moments,
fulfills much the same function in fiction
of this period as the marriage plot
did for the Victorian novel.
So any of you who have taken the
Victorian novel class professor used,
sells a course or have studied or
just read a lot of Jane Austin novels,
uh,
Dickens' novels and so on,
you will know what the marriage plot is.
The marriage plot is that engine of
storytelling that makes novels hang on a
structure of a couple and the question
of whether they will get together or not.
Now, there are all kinds of
stages in that development,
the development of that narrative.
Are the couples from
the same social class?
Are they from geographically, uh, uh,
contiguous places?
Do they have personalities that match?
Did their parents agree?
Are they related to each other secretly,
always a problem.
There are all kinds of things that can
go wrong for a couple trying to get
together and the Victorian novel was very
good at generating narrative from all
those kinds of complications.
Then there are different kinds of
outcomes that you can have in the novel
governed by the marriage
plot. One is the, the comedy.
That's when you get married at the end,
the couple gets married.
Then there's the tragedy. They don't
and they should have and we all know it.
So pride and prejudice would be an
example of the former kind Anna Karenina,
perhaps an example of the latter kind.
Even though that's a,
a novel really about adultery,
it totally depends on the
conventions of the marriage plot.
The plot works in much the same way.
So what is the identity pot?
I am going to give you a, uh,
an unusual sight in my class now,
and that is PowerPoint.
I think I'm sort of surprised
and delighted by this myself.
So we'll see how it works.
So if you're taking notes,
which I encourage you to do,
you will find your,
are bolded words that you can copy down
the identity plot, narrative form and
post 1945 fiction. Isn't that snazzy?
Okay. Whoops. I've already made my first
technological mistake. There we go.
Six elements of the identity plot.
Make sure you capitalize identity
and plot please. And also,
uh,
give me credit in the footnote
of your notes for that phrase.
The narrative of the identity plot novel
revolves around the question of how to
define and understand a character's
identity. Big surprise there.
Number two,
the character needs to be a member of
a minority within a larger society.
I am not going to ask you to volunteer
examples of these because it's just too
obvious
that our last three or four novels each
feature one of these characteristics or
all of them.
Yeah.
The third one is absolutely crucial to
the development of the identity plot and
that is that the character is also at
odds with the minority group of which he
or she is a part.
This is important because without it,
the identity plot gets really boring.
It doesn't have a lot of complication.
If all you have to do is realize
as you're going about your life,
wow,
I am a member of x or y group,
great,
and I know who I am now
done. That's, it's a really
short story actually, and it's a,
it's not a good short story either.
There's just not enough resistance
to the evolution of the plot,
so it's really important.
The drama of the identity
plot depends upon this.
Furthermore,
the character in question needs to be
conflicted about his or her difference
from the majority and about his or her
difference from the minority group.
Can anyone think of an example of this?
Anyone think of an example?
Yes.
Eli Kingspan
is conflicted about that kind of heritage
limits of women in Chinese culture but
also kind of latches onto
it and the more [inaudible]
absolutely. Yeah. So in case you
didn't hear you, I, uh, women warriors,
a great example of this,
Maxine,
that's what I'll call her when
I'm talking about the character.
Maxine Hong Kingston. Maxine is, uh,
feels alienated from Chinese
culture because of the
massage any she perceives in
that culture.
But she also turns to Chinese culture
as a way to identify herself and to give
her a positive self image.
As in that story of the woman warrior,
which I actually didn't ask you to read,
but there are other examples
in the stories that I did
ask you to read chapters
that I did ask you to read,
um, to give her that sense of,
of grounding as a person.
Other examples,
how about in the bluest
eye? Yes, that's okay.
Strangely minority,
but I think in French and Zoe,
they're a minority as intellectuals and
then Catherine is alienated from that
road.
Yeah. I think for Indians only
really does fit this model. Yes,
there are lots of different ways of
conceiving what it means to have,
and I'm a minority group at work in
these novels and I think Freddie and Zoe
definitely imagines a minority
group as the glass family.
They're big enough to be a group.
There are lots of children,
so you get that sense that there are
clan there sort of a tribe of themselves.
They have this peculiar
quality, their intellectual, uh,
sort of complexity and also their
artistic gifts, especially their,
their gifts in language.
Um,
and there is a conflict
between Frannie Ian's,
Darwin's Zoe is really held out as the
custodian of the glass family identity.
So it's he who instructs Franny and
brings her finally back into the fold.
And that's an example of the comic
ending other examples from other novels.
Can anyone do this for blue sky?
How am I piccola
be an example of this?
Okay.
Let me do it.
Pichola goes up the horrors,
apartment and fines there kind of
love and acceptance from those women.
Yeah.
That does not judge her for her ugliness.
That surrounds her with a rich verbal
culture as well as a culture of affection.
Okay.
It is a group that is,
has succeeded from the black community
itself but still maintains a certain tie.
Remember the prostitutes admiration
for the good Christian woman.
Okay.
That ties them to the prevailing
norms of the black community.
Yeah.
So pichola finds an ideal black
community within that small apartment.
Okay.
But she is alienated from that positive
black self image that she sees in those
women by her desire to identify
with white beauty to have blue eyes.
Okay.
And so that's how she would embody this.
Um,
Frieda is also an example
of this freedom and Claudia.
So, uh, actually if we take
the example of Claudia,
Claudia wants to be like, remember
the girl they called Merengue Pie,
the light skinned girl,
she wants to be liked her,
but at the same time she recognizes a
certain insipid quality to this girl.
She doesn't have the kind of strength
that Claudia and Frieda with the addition
of Pichola have as a little group that
doesn't pass judgment on their own
blackness.
Okay.
So that's again,
between Claudia Frida and Pichola,
there's another small
idealize black community,
but Claudia is somewhat conflicted both
about her membership in that little
group and her difference from the influx
of white blood into that community and
white aesthetic into that community.
So she echoes in a less dramatic way,
the same kinds of conflicts
that you see in Pichola.
Okay.
The fourth quality of the identity plot
is that authenticity and origin are
always at stake in the characters
quest for personal identity,
even when those things are absent.
Yeah.
So in the woman warrior,
we have an excellent example of this.
Um,
in the beginning,
yeah,
of the last chapter that I asked you to
read after she tells the whole story of
moon,
orchid and brave war kid
going to find moon or kids,
Chinese husband,
and confronting him with Moon
Orchid status as the first wife.
After you get this whole richly
imagined story full of dialogue,
the next chapter begins.
What my brother actually said was I drove
mom and second onto Los Angeles to see
aunt's husband's. Who got the other
wife? Did she hit him? What did she say?
What did he, what did he say? Nothing
much. Mom did all the talking.
What did she say? She said he'd
better take them to lunch. At least.
Which wife did he sit next to?
What did they eat? I didn't go.
The other wife didn't either.
He motion not to tell.
I would have told if I was his wife,
I would have told I would have gone to
lunch and kept my ears open. I, you know,
they don't talk when they eat. What
else did mom say? I don't remember.
I pretended to predict a pedestrian
broke her leg. So he would come.
There must've been more.
Didn't aunt get in one nasty word?
She must've said something. No,
I don't think she said anything.
I don't remember her saying one thing.
In fact,
it wasn't me. My brother told
about going to Los Angeles.
One of my sisters told
me what he told her.
They are layers of inauthenticity in
the origin of this story are deep.
There is no sense that the story we have
just been told in great detail has any
basis in fact,
and yet
this is a book that is patently
autobiography. I autobiographical.
It plays up the authenticity and
the unreliability of this voice.
We know that we cannot trust the
details of what is given to us.
And yet the narrative tries
to seduce us with them,
tries to persuade us by their very
dramatic quality and their detail.
And by the way, these stories embody
the voices of their characters.
That these are real stories.
Yes.
So the voice in Kingston that purports
to be a source of identity formation,
she's going to write herself into being
is an inauthentic voice.
Now,
there was a controversy about
Maxine Hong Kingston actually,
it's been going on for many decades.
It goes on today.
There's a scholar of Chinese
American literature named Frank Chin.
He's also a novelist himself.
He has accused Kingston and a few other
writers in the starkest terms of being
fakes and of being against Chinese
culture and of being puppets of white
culture.
Yeah.
Kingston's use of Chinese literature has
come under particular attack from Chin.
And this happened, uh, in, in one, uh,
of its incarnations or one
of its iterations of this,
this feud between the two.
Um, it actually happened at
a conference face to face.
And I know you must think that academic
conferences are always a thrill.
A minute. It's, it's not really usual that
they are, but I guess in this case, uh,
it was, um, so frank chin, I guess
shouted her off the stage. I can't,
I don't know all the details, but it
was, it was very exciting, I'm sure. Um,
nevertheless, the argument is serious.
It's an argument about authenticity.
The authenticity,
excuse me,
the authenticity of Kingston's
use of Chinese literature.
So imagine someone saying to John Barth,
wait a minute,
you changed the story of the Odyssey.
You're a fake.
That's essentially what Frank
Chin says to Maxine Hong Kingston.
It has a kind of traction to a certain
audience because the purity of an origin
of that kind matters if you think that
that's where authenticity of an identity
resides.
So if it's a cultural identity at stake,
the authenticity seems to
matter in a different way. Now,
Barth can give us a different
kind of example of this.
Authenticity is mental aliases,
voice in the mental Llyod
really his own is there.
Some being leftover that's
apart from that voice.
He says, my voice did olds
on, well, who's the my,
is he just reduceable to that voice?
Is He proteus?
Is proteus him?
Has his identity been lost in his
wrestling with that changing God?
Yeah.
The question of authenticity,
Hans men, Elias,
it haunts Ambrose when he is in the
throes of passion and he feels alienated
from himself. This is
passion. I am experiencing yet
that's a kind of inauthenticity.
He can't be grounded in the origin of
identity that we think of as the body.
So a lot of these novels make
a problem out of authenticity
when it doesn't seem like a problem.
Okay.
A novel is making a certain kind of
claim about identity right off the bat.
And that's,
that authenticity doesn't matter.
But in the context of the identity plot,
you know that it's on the radar screen.
Even if it isn't something
that is in the novel itself,
it's there, uh, bias, negative.
Finally,
there are comic versions and tragic
versions of the identity pot just as there
are of the marriage plot.
So the comic version gives us characters
that come to peace with their identity.
My favorite example of this is actually
novel. We're not reading in this course,
although I could've added,
it couldn't,
I could have done 10 novels in the first
seven weeks. I won't ask you to read it.
It's, uh, Barbara
Kingsolver pigs in heaven.
Okay.
In this novel, this is the most
extreme example. I know. Um,
I can't remember the full details now,
but um,
in that novel there is
a native American woman.
There's a native American child who
is adopted forcibly by in the forcible
adoptions and it's adopted
by a white family. I think
this is how the story goes.
And eventually after the Indian
family tries to get that child back,
it is discovered that the adoptive mother
was in fact a member of that tribe by
a very,
uh,
diluted bloodline and the,
the adoptive mother marries the
child's full blood grandfather.
Perfect, perfect. Uh,
comic ending for an identity plot novel.
Okay.
I would say that the bluest eye is,
uh,
our tragic version of this where
Pichola we'll never be at peace.
She is in fact a deranged by her,
her conflicted relationship to identity.
Now here is where we need a distinction
between literary fiction and genre
fiction. Now I could get into
lots of trouble for these claims.
They're fairly broad and ideally I
would want to give them more nuance,
but I think it's useful to
think about this distinction.
Incarnations of these kinds of narrative
conventions that we think of as
literary use those structures of
narrative as something to play off of or
something two and a habit while they
do a whole bunch of other things.
Think of the ways that Humbert and Nebach
off use the conventions of romantic
language to make us believe that
Humbert really loves Lolita.
There's something operatic about
the extremity of the situation.
We're given the extremity of the
use of those conventions in Lolita.
Well,
in this case,
some of our identity plot novels use that
plot to say something about language,
about literary history,
about tradition.
Some of them simply give us aesthetic
pleasure like the pleasure that we can get
from watching Barth use words,
make them funny,
be clever with them
so they may deliver an
artistic satisfaction that
has nothing to do with the
identity plot itself.
None.
There are incarnations of it that
don't reflect on any of those aesthetic
issues.
Don't reflect on the history
of the literary tradition.
Don't engage questions about language
that deliver instead conventional
predictable satisfactions of the genre.
And these we would call genre fiction.
And if you recall,
novakof talks a little bit
about pornography as genre
fiction that gives you
that predictable mechanical free song
of pleasure at the predictable place.
And he describes Lolita as rejecting
the convention of pornography.
You can think about his description as
applying also to the identity plot that
sometimes it functions and I think
they're Kingsolver novel really is a good
example of this where there are
predictable pleasures of the child being
enveloped by a loving family after
all the complications of her identity.
Finally,
it can all be resolved or there's a
kind of pleasure in that feeling that it
could never be resolved.
That tragic feeling.
So there's genre fiction
that can end that way too.
So other examples of genre fiction,
of course the detective novel is another.
Um, it is this, my argument
today is not to say that the,
this is the only convention
that are novels are working
with the detective genre
is president crying of lot 49.
That's something that you can think
about productively when you think about
adipose search for knowledge and clues.
There's a way that pension is playing
off that uh, that convention as
to make the distinction is not
to reject one for the other.
So literary fiction and genre fiction
are both part of what literary scholars
use to make, especially these
kinds of broad scale arguments.
So it's not really enough if you want to
argue about a whole period of literary
history to only skim off the
very most literary works,
your argument doesn't have a lot of
historical purchase if you do that.
If your ambition is to talk about more
narrowly the evolution of an art form,
that's a very legitimate move to make.
To Skim off just those literary examples.
But if your ambitions to say something
through your discussion of literature,
about culture, about politics, about
any other set of issues, philosophical,
historical questions,
you want to be able to demonstrate that
the things you're seeing in literary
fiction have a wider purchase and have
grabbed hold of the imagination of a,
of a larger set of people than the
people who read high literary novels.
Yeah.
So you can make different kinds of claims
depending on what combination of these
kinds of examples you use.
The identity pot obviously
has infinite variations.
Um, I mentioned just a few to
get you thinking about them.
The character seems to be a
member of the majority group.
This is actually in one
sense Frannie and Zoe's case,
as you mentioned,
uh,
it seems like they're much more in
a mode in a majority. They're white.
They are from an upper
class section of New York.
Um, they're distinguished by
their families, intellectual ism.
Similarly,
Ambrose could be said to
be in the majority group,
and certainly by the definition of
someone like Morrison or Kingston,
that fiction,
they're members of oh,
of a white Anglo Saxon
Protestant heritage,
the members of Ambrose's family.
But if you recall in Ambrose,
his mark,
the family is eccentric.
They too are marked by their
difference from the churches in town.
The independence of their thinking,
the uh,
skill with which they carve,
they have artistic skills.
Okay.
The character does not seem to be
conflicted about his membership,
the minority group. This can happen.
Where do you get the drama then?
Well,
sometimes you get the drama from the
efforts of the majority group against that
piece.
Will that person betray
their group or not?
So that's where the narrative tension
can come. If you see this variation,
the character resist the whole idea
of having an identity that stable.
You might think of Kingston
as an example of this. Um,
although I think you can argue
it both ways. I'm certainly,
she's not going to think you can
have an identity that stays still.
All those self revisions
that I even just from that little
passage that I read about where her story
comes from,
that's the suggestion that she's committed
to an identity that's changeable.
As this period moves on towards
the end of the 20th century,
that variation is much more common.
It gets more and more common.
The critique of identity in theory,
in the world of literary theory,
think of the work of Judith
Butler for example, uh,
in the late eighties and
stretching into the present, um,
very influential on undermining the idea
that you could have a stable identity
at all.
And that's where that term essentialism
identity essential ism comes from.
That's a very negative
idea by now by this point.
But in the 1970s and I would argue that
in Morrison's work you see us still a
commitment to the idea that you can really
be in a peaceful way African American
and that that's a stable grounded identity
or even that you can be white as a
stable,
grounded identity.
So I think some writers
earlier in the period, um,
persistent that idea,
even while most have gone to the
sense that identity is not stable,
there may be multiple characters whose
identities are at stake in the novel and
some subplots might end up as tragedy,
someone's comedy.
You can have a variation
with fiction based on fact.
We've seen that both in Richard
Wright and now in Kingston.
It raises the stakes of the fiction and
it suggests it's purchase on the reel to
write a fiction that is
sort of autobiography based,
partly in fact are mostly in fact it
suggests that what's going on in the
fiction is actually very
close to what we live.
And that's a kind of claim
for fiction in and of itself.
Yeah.
And uh, this is an example, this last one.
Identity identity is not
based on race or ethnicity.
When we think about identity,
we usually think of race or ethnicity,
but sometimes minority status is going
to be claimed or identities can be
claimed on religious or philosophical
grounds or just on the grounds of a
personality difference.
Someone who is strange sound
jurors sort of fond of this. Um,
catcher in the rye is an example.
I think of this where I'm Holden.
Caulfield is at odds with his world
because he just sees things really
differently.
Yeah.
One of the kinds of claims that you have
to be prepared to make if you're making
these broad period based claims is
that your claim is specific to your
particular time period.
Now you have to define your time period.
I'm uh, dealing with post World
War Two American literature,
somewhat arbitrary,
a cutoff for some scholars.
I think there are reasons to think that
it is a real cutoff having to do mostly
with, um, the changes in
the American cultural, um,
mass market in the years
after World War II. Um,
there are identity plots all over in
the history of the richer. So, uh,
the, the plot of mistaken identity
is a staple of renaissance comedy.
You think of midsummer night's dream,
for example,
secret identity is a
staple of gothic fiction.
This happens a lot in dickens,
other kinds of Victorian fiction,
artistic identity. Think of portrait
of the artist as a young man,
Joyce's novel about the
artistic formation of a person
that's especially important to modernism.
And you could also say the woman
warrior is an example of that version of
artistic self creation.
Um, racial identity.
There's a wonderful book called our
America by Walter Ben Michael's. Um,
he argues very persuasively that there
are whole ranges of genre fiction in the
1920s that are working
out a logic of race,
of a nativist logic of race
in the early 20th century,
that these novels are
governed by that logic.
So you have to be prepared to explain
how your feature is different from other
incarnations in the history of literature.
My contention is the identity,
as I'm describing it, um,
becomes a preoccupation of both literary
and genre varieties of writing in this
period.
So that suggests it's scope that it's
not just the concern of a few writers,
it's the concern of lots of writers.
It's different in the
degree of its presence.
So while Walter Ben Michael's argues
very persuasively for the racial logic of
popular Westerns, for example, or um,
for its relevance to Willa Cather's work,
it doesn't sit at the center of the
plots of those novels in the same way.
He can tease out the logic,
but it's not because that logic is
what the whole novels drama hangs on.
Some of the drama hangs on that.
But in the novels I'm
talking about in this period,
it has risen to the level of formula
such that you can hang the whole plot on
that structure and it's recognizable,
immediately recognizable.
So that's what I mean when I say in the
next bullet point that it achieves a
kind of solidity of formula,
a formulaic structure.
And finally, I want to argue as I've, uh,
been doing in a, in a sort of, um,
in passing in the last few lectures,
that these novels are working very closely
with things that are happening in the
culture in general.
So that tension between activism and
personal growth in the 1960s as modes of,
um,
of social action.
The question about whether you can
intervene in politics through culture is
everywhere in the 1960s.
And you can see a come to a head in the
1990s with the culture wars when both
liberals and conservatives
begin to fight over,
especially over the syllabi
of courses like this.
So if you think that it's worth fighting
a political fight over the syllabus
that we all read,
you are already committed
to a cultural politics.
So the end point of this is
a very widespread argument
in the 1990s about where
politics happens and that argument
revolves around novels that feature the
identity plot
cause those are the kinds of novels that
people thought of as either advancing
or uh,
or resisting the head Gemini of a White
Western tradition that was oppressive to
minority people.
Yeah.
This,
by the way,
this final incarnation of the identity
part is going to be very important to us
when we read the human stain.
That novel is deeply embedded
in that final iteration of it.
How else do you know it's a, it's a
dominant convention. Well it has an end.
This is another way you can
locate its historical specificity.
So it has its limits and you can see
it coming to its end when you see more
elaborate embellishment and variation on
that formula that writers have ambition
have to push it further and further.
Even writers of the genre fiction versions
have to address an audience looking
for the familiar pleasure,
but with just enough difference.
You know, you, you, you can think
of those Hollywood chase scenes,
they all look so much alike,
but the new ones always have to have
just that little bit more interesting
special effect or that much more dramatic
car flying off some high parapet.
Same thing with Annie,
uh, narrative formula.
And there comes a time when writers
of ambition simply change the subject.
And I'm going to argue that even the
Roth is still thinking in these terms.
The other novels that reading,
starting next week,
uh,
and into the end of the semester
are beginning to change the subject.
So one subject that comes
up very powerfully in those
novels is the subject of
history.
It's not unrelated to identity,
but it is distinctly different.
And so in Cormac McCarthy for example,
there is a a a palpable engagement
with history and an Edward P.
Jones in a novel that really seems like
a classic outgrowth of the identity part
novels,
especially of Toni Morrison is really
much more about the terror of history than
it is about the dramas of identity.
So we will see how that
subject gets changed.
Okay.
When we read the woman warrior,
we might feel that it is very,
very conventional.
Okay.
Because it does so much of what I have
just described that the identity pot
does.
Hmm.
I
think in a way that would
be short changing it.
Some novels look dated
or look formulaic because they have been
incredibly successful and I think the
bluest sky and woman warrior are
examples of those kinds of novels.
Woman Warrior and what this is one of
Frank Chin's corals with it is widely,
widely taught. I always think hard
about including it on my syllabus.
Sometimes that's a reason to include it
on a syllabus as evidence in an ongoing
unfolding argument. Sometimes
it isn't. In this case,
I've decided pretty securely that it is.
It belongs here as a piece of evidence
in this unfolding argument about what's
happening in the historical period.
Woman Warrior is widely taught.
It is one of the foremost examples
of this kind of identity writing.
It has some literary satisfactions.
Some of those stories
are really compelling.
She's very good at living a character.
She's wonderful at
reproducing the dialogue.
She reflects on the quality of writing.
She has self conscious about the
construction of her narrative.
And so we can see an artist telling the
story of her own coming to being as an
artist in the way she tells these stories.
There's all kinds of things
you can close read in here. Um,
and I'm going to run out of time.
Uh, let me just show you one thing.
This is at the very end,
at two oh seven,
this is when she's told the story about
her grandmother taking the family to the
opera and how bandits tend to rob the
houses that have been abandoned while
families are at the opera.
Instead, in this case,
the bandits attack the audience
in the experience.
Uh,
the families all broken up in the attack.
By daybreak,
when my grandmother and
mother made their way home,
the entire family was home safe proof
to my grandmother that our family was
immune to harm. As long as they went
to plays, they went to many plays.
After that, the grandmother's
logic is completely twisted here.
It's turned upside down.
It doesn't make any sense.
They got attacked when
they went to the play,
so they go to plays in order to stay
safe because they happen to survive that
attack.
The reason why we're given that logic is
that this book is full of stories about
insanity
and remember from the story about moon
or a kid in sanity in this story is
defined as telling one story over and
over again insisting on the same story.
She becomes paranoid,
essentially a paranoid schizophrenia.
That means that sanity,
healthiness is found in
multiplicity illogic.
It's a kind of contradictory claim about
the status of sanity and storytelling.
So the illogic of this little moment at
the very end of the book reaches back to
all those other examples of illogic and
insanity that we see throughout classic
new critical technique for building the
meaning of a certain trope across the
writing.
Yeah.
The other thing also of course to think
about is the fact that this takes place
around plays,
that it's art that's held
out as being the lucky thing.
It's art that's at the center.
And this of course,
especially the play reaches back to
Maxine's descriptions of her childhood
drawings where she painted page after
page after page of black worrying her
teachers.
But for the young Maxine,
what she saw in a black page was the,
the curtains of a theater ready
to open endless possibility.
So it's that very appreciation of the
play of the dramatic shared by the
grandmother repeated even in this,
uh,
inarticulate artistic creation of the
child that builds the sense of artistic
identity as an inherited one.
Yeah.
So I'm,
I'm not going to go on with this,
but I just show you that little passage
and suggest some of the ways that it's
built up over the course of the book
to show you that Kingston's novel or
autobiography,
even though it fulfills the convention
so completely that it looks like genre
fiction. If you located in 1976
when it was first published,
it's not, it's not at the
end of a long line of these.
It's at the beginning.
So it is one of the first popular books
to bring together Barthes insights with
those of the identity politics beginning
in the 60s so Morrison and Kingston
both are some of the first to take
modernist self consciousness about writing
and combine it with this
interest in identity.
So that's why I think it's sort of doesn't
do her justice to see this as genre
fiction as to as to predictable because
it was one of the early versions of it.
So next week we're going to start reading
housekeeping. Just hold on one step
and I want you to think about whether
housekeeping fits the identity plot model,
and if it does, how it does, and if
it doesn't, how it doesn't. Um, it,
that identity plot model was very
influential in its early reception.
So I want you to think about
how that worked. Thank you.